ganhou o lugar de pessoal do que quem
fala é o bar que seja muito menos a mais
ou melhor eu estou aqui com uma arma
deve só por aí a coisa de bom solo eu
consegui achar que está a manter sólido
bem por dentro mesmo quatro cavalos em
foto de bons solos temos aqui então pra
fazer um teste de tiro aqui com a nossa
é soft eu tenho aqui um convidado muito
especial entrar em trair a apresentar o
vídeo apresentado
[Risadas]
bom pessoal nós temos que combinar que é
um profissional dias só fila e costuma
que esta arma eu tenho a imagem vou
ficar
temos mais uma só tacada só pára choques
morning sun do projeto
o processo funciona pra quem não sabe o
que quer só é como se fosse futebol mas
as balas são costa e não há 32 muito dói
mesmo aqui tem um cantador que o leva às
bolinhas e as armas que supostamente
manual é só fazer assim um disparo mas é
em quatro é muito boa porque o chile
essa área aqui é uma réplica é muito
difícil porque ela tem o mesmo peso é
igualzinha em quatro e é elétrica é
muito difícil aí
esse é o carregador está aqui dá para
500 mil imaginem só quer levar um tiro
de 500 bolas e com um tiro só que faltou
mais bonitas jogos então é automática
dos valores mas também é automático lei
é verdade
321 sua dúvida e 2 vai ser apenas o que
o bernardo ensinar uma disparada que é
só porque eu ainda não sei mas se nós
conseguirmos ficar aqui os 100 mil likes
eu prometo que eu faço aqui uma guerra
de só ficar em casa ao cair portanto
deixem o nosso leque e vamos lá então
quem está aqui na sexta o pessoal então
nós temos aqui uma duas três quatro
cinco seis garrafas e nós vamos
implementar aqui deus conseguimos
partilhar algumas pará e 100 metros né
acho que é pouco e temos aqui mais
remédios pequenos que é mais difícil
você estar na fifa depois vamos começar
pelas garrafas por hora
só procuro ficar sem balas durante o
jogo tem aqui uma coisa que os pilotos
pedro louro seja mais rápido
nossa equipe só estamos aqui e 25 metros
mais momentos do álbum sonic youth
garrafa estão lá no fundo só vou
experimentar só dar um tiro disse pai
pelo ala muito longe
no regresso só olha agora todas as
etapas da vida porque tem boi poderia
aqui em cima pessoal lá em cima tem tipo
maneira tudo isto tudo isso foi
basicamente você tem que fazer é apontar
essa minha primeira vez este buraco tem
que pontuar aqui mais ou menos também é
egoísta plantamos as garrafas - mãe não
se sentar aqui com a nossa chamada lei
do bem tudo apontar a posição de costa
rica cuba sim 100 milhas em miran citei
lineu
[Música]
só fiquei sem balas disse não ter
sentido e brotou estudos só vamos lá
então que começaram o desafio do tiro na
garrafa e não vai levar cinco tiros e
quem perder vai roubar um tiro de
softwares costa jr lembra tal e tal
pelas começa agora a sentir o peso do 12
chega em cinco tiros um acertou quatro
balas rua tão fogo
se não for agora dar pra mim a rússia
espera agora que agora é que agora estou
a 73 não 222 bola rolar
só vamos lá então tomar um tiro nas
costas embora não a mesma distância a
mesma distância
[Música]
vou fazer contato 32 na cabeça 2 a 1
o próximo a sair
agora vamos tentar aqui com alvos bem
mais pequenos que parece bem mais
difícil por isso aqui é o rafael este
aqui é o tio rex e esta aqui é
um lapso ao próximo desafio embora agora
o desafio que é quando nós é um quadro e
vamos usá-lo em semi automático portanto
vamos lá ver como é que tem que ser
organizado agora é agora alvo mais
pequeno em quatro ou mais índice começa
luvas foi o forro comecei tudo hoje no
rio
ela citou rafael e multiplex prova só o
secretário adjunto do estojo de falta de
maxwell tele até fui vasco empata
tecnicamente está sendo discutido foi o
zagueiro na equipe são tratadas no
respeito e no outro tipo só com um carro
alguém vai ficar pronto
eu não vou aguentar embora só 32
o grupo tentava acertar na bola rolando
já está no fundo da mala muito fácil a
um rio muito fácil acertar na hora de se
ouvir ouvir olha aí depois outra vez
achou folha você dá a seu tempo final
deste ano a hipotecar série vou mostrar
como estou só vai terminar a china
aplica tudo brutal porque o passat
flamengo só vamos fazer o seguinte eu
vou dar um tiro em cada um aqui da casa
o méxico não vou usar essa arma testa do
homem muito ea loja mesmo é um eu acho
que só usar o chope ano vamos tentar
acertar aqui o pessoal da casa lembra
daquelas com essa bola agora também
vamos lá pessoal é algo que fica
salvador de guaraí
tcheca em cima do s
no final da época todos os portugueses
sabem que eu já faço também permite meio
antes não quer assim chato
[Aplausos]
agora no nosso esporte fora para não me
dá medo de falar catarina está lá em
cima porque ela vai casar só para fazer
uma visita então ela estava no quarto eu
vou tentar ameaçar lugar no time vamos
ver a reação dela
o espírito santo domingo e não voltou
o pessoal então é isso vai ficar porque
os filhos já sabe se quiserem virar uma
guerra aqui entra a casa toda deixem sem
lag
neste vídeo cansado e só fique bem e até
a próxima